hello everybody and welcome to the
brand-new let's play of the corridor now
this is actually an indie game that I
found on my own I don't know if anyone
else suggested it you may have but as
far as I know this is a pretty recent
thing
is very cool anyway this is just a small
thing that I found I don't know how long
it is
I think it's short because I think it's
in early development or anything like
that but it got great reviews in terms
of atmosphere and in terms of the scares
it has I want to give it a try oh also
it's in Russian so I don't know if I'll
be able to read or understand anything
that's going on but I'm pretty sure
you're scared scared so I'm guessing
this top one play the corridors in it
okay here we go
yeah those it okay I'm ready I am ready
my body is ready okay I woke up in the
middle of the night and I feel nervous
for no reason okay I feel nervous for no
reason okay WASD mouse look click click
click do nothing can open drawers pick
up stuff approach I can Crouch crouch
kinda kinda go faster okay we got a book
here hey don't don't push me oh I can
jump high jump on you yeah take that you
stupid glass of wine bottle 1 jumping on
the bow what uh-oh break in the game
here okay so I think there's anything in
here
oughta be flipped / F ah that would be
the corridor I'm wondering if this is
like sort of like scp-087 where you just
got to go down the stairwell but this
one you got to go down the corridor
until you die I wonder if that's what
the deal is okay anyway I guess there's
nothing in here so let's go it's very
strange
I don't remember such a long corridor in
the hotel mmm very strange indeed okay
but I'm not worried about the strange
I'm worried about winning the game I'm
not sure if it was made in like the
Unity engine or something older looks a
bit older than the Unity engine maybe an
older version of
oh is that okay and nothing so tough and
brave take on any corridor hey Bill I
get the pills can I get the booze sure I
can't knock over that Bob oh okay fine
never mind that
okay I can't get those I don't think I
don't even think I've an in there's the
FPS counter I don't even think I have an
inventory or something
yeah well was that
sound like someone handing a pool table
ah who knocked over this chair
ooh someone's knocking over chairs
I don't like that can another bottle
knock you over plumber okay no it don't
matter
you okay Jer yeah okay Norma
corridor got dark Bandar
gonna bring it on I'm ready for you I'm
ready
shut up be laughing at me
but when your stupid game then you'll be
laughing last let's do it again
it's actually I really like that music
it kind of stopped hello hi okay
hi someone crack this table in half
alright then laptop eyes are cool weird
Wow god I remember that last Super
reminds me of the zombie a separate
picture I've solved I've seen before
huh
ah a bit of a jump scare but that
it did its job okay oh boy all right oh
it's kind of like is this be SCP who
eats them someone crack this table and
have to ah table needs to clean up this
wall this wall somebody need to clean up
all these walls for as a maintenance
definitely needed good what good okay
things just took a turn for the weird
there is a Killington why is there stuff
in here and what do its cocoon coming oh
crap the music changed
I know the music shifted I can hear like
I can hear this ah our two daiquiri
you're like a subtle bit of like that
whoa oh okay all right
Oh what the what is this damn worm
intestine turd thing good lord
ah hey was oh man was it just a random
desk here what's going on I don't even
know Oh gross
Rudy hello skull okay
love that music very very nice
oh man I swear weird was it someone
there no okay
alright oh hello I got done huh huh oh
okay well this I don't think this is
better but it least it looked nicer
cleaner Oh what is that what is that
what is that what is that was that was
that was that what is that what is that
shut up shut up what is that what is it
huh oh that's something the other been
moving holy crap
always hauling me oh [ __ ] Oh close it
good good oh I got shivers is that the
chest
that's a bench oh just standing there
was it doing it I was doing it
hey you want some I don't I can click
them what no okay there we go
close that door then stay right there
you
the blood or wine I have a feeling it's
blood this time ha I can't move I hear
somebody breathing behind me
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no you oh
[ __ ] you oh oh okay alright okay let go
I can sprint oh oh let's go go oh let's
go okay shut up shut up shut your face
Oh breaking oh it's working it's working
oh my god what is this it was like
intestine see Oh what is that
haha oh gosh pigs are taking Oh what the
hell
oh it's like torsos
it's so weird oh man oh-oh-oh back to
normal uh-huh
back to normal miss okay okay all right
fine fine fine
oh man I don't know how long this is oh
look
oh man I don't know how many levels are
in this game so um I'm just gonna keep
going I think it's short how's this a
nightmare I hope yeah you hope oh don't
tell me oh I gotta go through a whole
nother corridor okay yeah I'm just gonna
play through till the end now that
doesn't look good look like a corridor
either I got bunny okay oh oh oh come on
that's it Oh
how's it I guess oh ah house much
shorter than I thought
that's not even barely one episode I
guess it's an indie game so there are
plenty of games like this that are on my
list to play that are just okay that was
pretty good though that was like really
good the atmosphere was good I feel like
they could have done a lot more with it
but maybe it's just like a small hobby
project or something like that
either way still very good and I will
provide a link for where I found it in
the description below so if you want to
play it yourself click in the link in
the description below and man it was
good I wish it had a name of the person
earth there is a name guys name was
Russian so I actually read it but anyway
there'll be a link to where i found it
so hopefully i'll give credit where
credit's due there so anyway I really
enjoyed that though it's good for a
small one so anyway thank you all so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye